mr. turtle congratulations and very
welcome to Stockholm City Hall thank you
this year two of the Nobel laureates are
from France your country what does that
mean to the French people I think
there's a lot of pride is a lot of pride
in the government in the streets
everywhere because of course a Nobel
Prize is very well known in France and
when I walk in the streets of Toulouse
or even Paris your people recognize me
and stop me and you know I even had
people crying because when the met with
mere it's very touching and you know it
says something about the Nobel Prize too
yes so the feeling of national pride is
growing in France because of you and
Patrick Majdanek modelo of courses is a
very well-known figure in France most
people i've read his books and its
various very nice person too also very
shy yes um how does it feel for you to
be to causing such feelings of national
pride well it's kind of strange because
you know all at once you become you know
you're under the light projector and a
very happy about it at the same time
it's I I was out to my family to my
friends to my cursors to my students so
I'm glad to receive a price on their
behalf yeah your Prime Minister is of
course very proud also and and he talked
about a slap in the face for those who
take pleasure in criticizing France what
did he mean well I think he means I
cannot speak for him but I think he
means that actually there's a lot of
talent in France and I believe that's
true there is a lot of human capital and
Francis as assets and and and she'll do
well so so you cannot just engage in in
French bashing friends are some
difficulties that's correct but they
also reasons for hope and who is
criticizing France right now well
sometimes abroad days there are some
criticisms of friends that were either
way the reforms are coming to slowly but
and I hope they were they will but you
know in the end I think we have lots of
facets and if I didn't believe in France
I will not live in France mm-hmm okay I
know it bothers you a little bit that
people in general are not enough trained
in economics why is that a problem well
I think it's true in every country
almost but particularly in France I
think part of the reason is that much of
the economy has been run by it by the
state in the past the state has been
very powerful so the decision will not
Rihanna Connery ground now it's a bit
different because of course we have
independent agencies competition
competition policy agencies regulators
central banks lots of decisions are
taken in Brussels or abroad and
therefore you have to use economic
arguments but still there is some some
lag in acquiring the culture of
economics and why is is a problem that
people are not aware of only well it can
be a prime of course for governments
because the government's if the public
opinion is not aware of what's going on
what what the stakes are it's difficult
for them to engage in reforms and who is
responsible for changing this well I
think we have a responsibility we we r
economist of course the media to and
everybody has a responsibility in us
understanding better i kinda mixed in
here with us what is it it's very
complicated stuff isn't it it is hard to
understand sometimes it is sometimes
they ought to understand that also
simple things so I think if we if we
just train people a little been more to
think about I know how to sync in
economic terms and you know that's also
my duty my duty as well I know with a
Nobel Prize okay well a little bit more
of that yeah if you have time if I have
fun it will be busy okay thank you so
much for talking to me and please have a
wonderful evening yes thank you very
much haha thank you
you